[Música]
los estragos del break ya se sienten en
el reino unido en la actualidad hay
problemas de suministro de mano de obra
y también desabastecimiento como ya lo
comentábamos los trabajadores europeos
ya no llegan al reino unido- y por esto
muchos puestos sobre todo considerados
de baja calificación se quedan sin
cubrir ante esto la asociación nacional
de porcinos aseguró que ya van por lo
menos unos 600 cerdos que han sido
sacrificados en ese territorio por falta
de la mano de obra en mataderos y en
general en el sector de procesamiento de
la carne el primer ministro británico
boris johnson reconoció que los cambios
tras el prat se tomarán mucho tiempo y
por ello ya quiero saludar entonces a
nuestra primera invitada del día es joan
a amaia politólogo e internacionalista
profesora e investigadora de la
universidad de essex quien se en reino
unido y también de la juve si él gracias
a johanna por estar aquí con nosotros en
directo américa en france 24 ahora la
preocupación entre la población ahora es
no sobre la crisis de gasolina porque se
nos extiende más no como ya estamos
comentando la falta de conductores mano
de obra para diferentes sectores que
pongan río la navidad una época tan
preciada para todos los humanos
raúl buenos días gracias por la
invitación
ciertamente en la escasez de conductores
está haciendo un punto crítico en el
abastecimiento de productos y alimentos
la mano de la nueva política migratoria
premia la mano de obra calificada sobre
todo a nivel de posgrado pero no se
pensó que este tipo de políticas que
establecieron los conservadores pues
generará un desabastecimiento general de
mano de obra de servicios básicos
después de la pandemia
si bien en la vida cotidiana no se
perciben
esos efectos más allá del
desabastecimiento de gasolina no ha
habido aún un desabastecimiento serio de
alimentos por ejemplo
si digamos que la presión mediática
sobre el tema en torno a la navidad como
lo mencionó previamente este tiene que
ver tal vez más con con una estrategia
sensacionalista de los medios pienso que
de todas maneras el reino unido tiene
una capacidad importante de establecer
alianzas económicas para para generar el
abastecimiento de productos básicos
si con suerte logran diversificar los
socios más allá de la unión europea
así es joana y le preguntó entonces cómo
afecta todos estos desafíos a las
finanzas públicas de reino unido
pues más
hay que tener en cuenta que
más allá del efecto del break si tenemos
de fondo la la pandemia así que el
desabastecimiento de mano de obra
el hecho de que muchos de estos
trabajadores pararon ha hecho que las
finanzas se verán seriamente
afectadas el ministro de la cartera que
podríamos llamar de hacienda de
ministros etcétera
ha anunciado que
subsidios y políticas importantes para
apoyarlos para los trabajadores que
pararán así que en
el intercambio el mercado se tiene que
ver afectado y se está viendo afectado
en diferentes áreas pero sobre todo en
el sector
financiero creo que este es uno de los
sectores más más relevantes respecto a
la
relaciones con la unión europea ya que
los bancos británicos prestan casi 1.4
trillones a los gobiernos y compañías de
la unión europea entonces
creo que este es uno de los entre muchos
sectores el que en términos monetarios
está viendo más afectados ahora llevan a
también como lo comentábamos previamente
los titulares de la prensa con rossi
también un tema del día de hoy no cómo
está afectando entonces este proyecto al
conflicto entre las fronteras en irlanda
que iba a pasar en esto cómo lo ven
hacia dónde se encamina
creo que hay un conflicto
respecto al tema de aduanas que es
bastante relevante pero el trasfondo
político y cultural de este conflicto
nacional pues reviva este este espíritu
nacionalista que es el que se ha ido
cultivando a partir de las discusiones
del break sit yo creo que esta es una un
tema que merece una discusión más
profunda y de largo aliento pero
indiscutiblemente el tema de aduanas es
el tema que se debe atender de manera
más urgente y ante eso también muchos
analistas dicen que estamos de cara a
una guerra comercial entre londres y
bruselas como lo usted
sobre todo en el tema pesquero sí
sí por supuesto
evidentemente y luego de las
negociaciones
extendidas y fallidas de invex y de la
unión europea trató de ofrecer de muchas
formas la permanencia del reino unido en
dentro de la unión europea sin embargo
pues ante este cierre definitivo la
naturaleza de los mercados se centrará a
la competencia para la
diversificación del abastecimiento de
nuevos productos porque aunque
mediáticamente se venda más la idea de
que el reino unido ha sido el más
afectado evidentemente europa también se
ve afectada sobre todo como lo mencioné
anteriormente en el sector financiero y
esto hace que pues estos dos gigantes se
robustezcan para entrar a competir
en la
en el mercado y en la adquisición de
nuevos socios y en la expansión de
nuevos mercados joana entonces
despedirla quiero preguntarle hasta
cuándo podemos ver esta crisis se va a
grabar
esta es una crisis de largo aliento
estamos usando hasta ahora en el periodo
de ajuste
todas estas políticas
tienen
implicaciones no sólo nacionales sino
evidentemente a nivel internacional y en
el convence y en el comercio
internacional que en un período no menor
a 5 años tendrá el efecto pues joana
gracias por su tiempo por su análisis de
lo que está pasando con el price y los
estragos que ya empieza a sufrir en
unido también por supuesto del lado de
la unión europe pues qué va a pasar ya
lo veremos a lo largo del tiempo gracias
llevan a por estar con nosotros en
directo américa